hot breath so the next one is from
patrick fowler he says without a set
list do you write jokes down
or do you record them or do you just
keep them all in your brain
i don't write them down i i do do my
mind map
thing is when i first you know so
um
oh i'm trying to show you okay so i like
a hundred times
a long time ago i have a bit that's out
called when i get into uber's
i lie to the uber driver right and then
i would just write one
two what's the lie i'm in phoenix
and we paint lighthouses okay right and
then i start asking myself
a lot of questions about whatever bit
that i wrote down
right so why why would you lie to an
uber driver what are the
greatest lies you ever told that did
anyone ever
think that you actually did that job
what would be like to have that job
uh do i know anybody who has that job so
now from one question
i have a list like i have a list of
things that i can fill in
about that bit then from there you've
kind of built a whole story
and you could go now that highlighted
uber driver bit
might have five different entry points
or five different subcategories
so i'm so from thinking about that i
might be like
so one time i told the guy i was a
chocolatier
and then that spins off to wonder
what's the training like to be a
chocolatier indebted
like you have all these parallel
developments just from that one idea
so that's a new way that i kind of
started writing like i used to write on
stage to answer
his point i used to write on stage and
then i'd record every show
and then i would pay to have that show
it's like a few bucks just transcribed
so i take my hour every saturday i take
saturday for a show
right just record it and then there's a
bunch of cert like
you know the service i've used for 10
years but there's a million more
um you send it off to them and three
days later
you get it all printed out and then you
read your act
so if you did anything new you can kind
of like highlight it or whatever where
you go
okay this is you know this is the new
bit and then from there
you can kind of go my dog's in a bar for
the rest of this interview by the way
but that's that's that's how i wrote it
down though
um yeah did i answer that yeah
yeah i answered that question so i i
used to write on stage
and then i would then i would transcribe
it and only recently
did i start doing that mind mapping
thing
um because i was on a plane and i saw
this guy
sketching he had he would like sketch an
eagle
and then he would turn the like i'm
talking he would sketch for like a
minute or if if that he would sketch for
like a minute
and then he turned the page and then it
was like a statue of liberty
was waves
and then he'd flip it back to the eagle
and just the whole flight he was
he was burning through these like four
or five pictures whatever it was
and i asked him i go you don't you don't
spend any time on a picture
like what's your thought process and he
says if he stares at a picture too long
his brain starts re-looking at
shitty drew and what that sucks or he
doesn't know
whether he should make the wings
featherier or longer
so the second his brain starts
questioning what he's doing
he he blazes over to the next picture
and then he
then he deals with that picture and he
just keeps going back
so i went and got a book
bought a notebook and just went to a
coffee shop and literally
i lied to uber drivers things i used to
stress out about a kid as a kid
uh what what room in my house do i hate
the most
and i would and then i would go back why
would i lie to an uber driver
i used to stress about reading out loud
as a kid and then before i knew it
i like maybe a couple songs and think i
looked i'm like there's
three premises here that all have a
thing
and maybe it took me i think i gave
myself almost like a speed round
like i did you know i remember even
timing i don't remember like three like
one song
maybe two songs where i just started you
know going as fast as i could
and then you were just done um so that's
like the new way it's weird i've been
doing comedy
like i said for you know since 87 and
it's weird that you have a new you know
it's kind of exciting that you can
having suddenly a new way of doing
things
yeah so you just haven't i you have an
idea and then asking questions about
that dia
almost unearths the actual punch lines
behind it
like the why yeah like do you have an
idea that
yeah like do you have an idea that that
you're working on
um i think the most recent one has been
popped it's my my wife always has
her phone on like one percent and it
kills me
like okay so okay okay so so what
but so what you would do is you would
write
my wife has phone on one percent and
then you would bubble it
okay and now we're gonna ask a billion
questions
why does she keep why does she run it to
the to
the to the very end what else in her
life
does she let almost go to the very end
but you know maybe our car should say
on the gas one percent maybe instead of
gallons it should say how many percent
from from right so
do you what what when do you plug yours
in
uh 90 so can a 90 percenter
be a thing if you were on an island
would she wait
to like so suddenly we have this whole
story about you and your wife
and all it really is is she only has one
percent on her phone
but now we've just taken it now for some
reason if you go back to my
long ramblin this now i got you and your
wife and car getting gas
off of just that her cell phone chunk
right and then you guys are now where
you guys driving to you just know she
doesn't you don't you don't have gas
where were you going we were going to a
why were you going to eggs she wanted to
throw axes what date night ideas do you
do
now now we went from your percentage of
your phone
to an axe throwing date to you guys
running out of gas
to you guys arguing and use going i only
have one percent left
of this in this argument i think i've
done like so now we've just told the
whole story
that's you know five minutes 10 minutes
long by the time you're done
and you have all these in and outs and
then you don't need a set list because
you know you're going to do
your wife cell phone bit that's gonna
have all these sides and you know
all part of the story oh my gosh
dude i've done over 200 interviews
with comedians and that may be the best
joke breakdown we've been able to
capture on here that was amazing
wow good i couldn't repeat it because i
don't know what i just said that but
that's the creativity right you do it in
a burst and you're just like i don't
know what happened but it's there now
that was great